we are waiting for president Trump to
make his way from Trump Tower to The
District Courthouse here in lower
Manhattan late this morning he'll be
accompanied by Secret Service as he
arrives at the court and passes by
dozens and dozens of news crews hoping
to get a glimpse of him there's a heavy
police presence as demonstrators are
expected along the Route and outside of
the courthouse here as well once the
president gets here the first step will
be administrative he'll fill out papers
have his fingerprints taken and then be
escorted down the hall to face the judge
and at that time he and the public for
the first time will learn the extent of
the charges against him the whole thing
is expected to take just a couple of
hours after that we'll hear from the
district attorney Alvin Bragg the man
who is overseeing the prosecution in
this case he'll be addressing the media
and talking about it and answering
charges that he's doing this for
political reasons and and president
Trump will return to Florida where he is
also expected to make statements to the
public